just a bit intermittent that was all
okay thank you
it went dead onto us
so chair the the feed is now live
to youtube i'm going to click the record
button and you're ready to start
whenever
whenever sees thank you this meeting is
being
recorded thank you and good afternoon
and welcome to everyone this afternoon's
planning committee meeting
before we start i would like to confirm
which committee members and officers are
here
thank you chad i can do that for you um
so in the meeting room today
from the planning committee we have
councillors william armitage
jane barry andrew cooper peter elliott
mark foster carol huckabee
sorry i'm just going to meet america
from there mopotts alan
powell tracy reader jackie ridgeway
kathy rouse yourself donovan who's
joining us from the chamber
and ross shipman um also in the meeting
room today
is councillor carolyn renick who's
actually in her capacity's award
counsellor
adrian kirkham who's the planning
manager jim fieldson who's our legal
representative for this meeting and
members of the governance team who are
supporting
thank you chair thank you
as you know we have a protocol in place
for a meeting in this virtual way which
i would now like the meeting facilitator
to read out
thank you chair so this is just a
reminder to all members to keep your um
microphones muted but your cameras on
for the duration of the meeting
um the protocols that will be in place
will be that
as as per the meeting etiquette that we
have for our virtual meetings
and it's to behave as if we were in the
council chamber
reminding members to speak through the
chair at all times
if you could indicate to speak by either
raising your hand using the raise hand
function
using the chat bar and i will have the
closed captions on for this meeting so
if i do see you i'll put a message
across the screen
which will also help the chair to see
who's in line waiting to speak
if when you are speaking if you could
introduce yourself
as counselor x representing y ward
so the public is aware who you are
um voting for this meeting will be done
by roll call for each application
um just a quick reminder remember to be
mindful of your home surroundings as the
meeting is being live streamed and
recorded
thank you chair thank you
we move on to the agenda and item one is
apologies for absence
thank you chair there are no apologies
that absence received for this meeting
thank you
the second item is declaration of
interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interest
and or other interests not already on
their register of interest
in any item on the agenda can withdraw
from this meeting at the appropriate
time
have we received any declarations in
advance
no chair no declarations received in
advance of the meeting
do any members have any declarations
thank you
no no no no
thank you item three minutes of the last
meeting
we now have the minutes of our two
meetings held on tuesday the 22nd of
september 2020
we will start with the minutes for the
morning meeting
are we all happy that these are a
correct record and if so is there a
muther
move it sure is there a seconder
thank you all those in favor
thank you
all right we'll move to the second set
of minutes which
follow on so is there a if everyone's
happy is there a mover for these
more witcher seconder
all in favor
thank you emotions being carried for
those
item 4 is the planning applications
that moves us onto this main business
and as you can see we have three
applications each of which has its own
report
marked items 4a 4b and 4c
i am happy with this and intend to
consider them in that order
however before we do this i would like
the clerk to explain for the benefit of
members
speakers and public who are watching on
youtube
how they will be dealt with
right thank you chair um this is the
procedure for considering applications
at the meeting
we will consider the three applications
in the order that they are set out on
the agenda
the chair will introduce the application
and ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received
since the agenda was issued the late
items agenda supplement
has been published on the council's
website and the link has been sent to
committee members
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
the screen showing this presentation
will be shared with those attending the
meeting
they can also be seen on the council's
website through its youtube channel
following on from this the chair will
ask each of the speakers
any ward members first followed by
objectors
then the applicants or their agent to
speak to the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views
using the conferencing facility
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions
if necessary to clarify any points they
have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate and for determination by a vote
now a note for speakers once the
application you've come to speak on has
been dealt with
you may leave the virtual meeting room
if you choose to remain then please mute
your microphone
and turn off your camera you will not be
allowed to participate further in the
meeting
from that point as you're aware
this meeting is being live streamed the
council will make a recording
for purposes of preparing the minutes
once the minutes have been approved by
the committee then this recording will
be deleted
but please note that others may also
record the live stream
from the internet thank you chair
thank you we'll move on to the first
application
number ned forward slash two zero
four slash zero zero six four eight
the application for the conversion of an
existing stable building to a single
dwelling
hilltop stable quarry hill troway
in the line of our normal practice i'm
going to ask the planning officers to
tell us
about any late comments reports that
have been produced and for the planning
manager to give a brief presentation
showing any photos and plans of the site
the meeting facilitator will share the
presentation on screen
this means that i might find it
difficult to see everyone
therefore i will allow the officers to
complete their presentation
and ask members to reserve any points of
order or questions about the process
until the end there will be plenty of
time for you to ask questions later on
i'm now going to go over to our planning
officer for the first application
good afternoon thank you chair this is
uh an application
seeking consent to change the use of an
existing stable building to a dwelling
and create an associated garden area
with parking spaces to serve it
the applicant chair state the stable is
no longer in use
members will need to note share that the
site is located in the greenbelt
and the moss valley conservation area
the stabilist timber and timber frame
chair the applicant states works to the
floor
including introducing a damp proof
course potential strengthening of the
roof
although it's not clear if a new roof
would be needed
insulation and other damp proofing are
required to facilitate the cursion
existing openings would be used
but eight new roof lights are proposed
in the green belt chair members will
note that the reuse of buildings is not
inappropriate development where the
building is permanent of a substantial
construction
and in other respects preserves openness
in this instance chair officers consider
that the works required to facilitate
the conversion
are excessive and the building is not of
a permanent
and substantial construction officers
have therefore concluded share that the
conversion proposes inappropriate
development
there are no very special circumstances
to otherwise justify it
in terms of impact on openness chair and
the constant impact on the conservation
area
officers consider the harm in both cases
is neutral
due to the enclosure of the site by
trees and the level of existing
development which we'll see in a second
on the photographs
i definitely additionally chairs members
will note officers have assessed
the proposed works and how future
occupiers of the building would
experience the building as converted
officers have concluded that the living
conditions of those
future occupiers would not be acceptable
reliant in some cases on
artificial light officers chair do not
consider the factors
outweigh their conclusions or the facts
outweigh their conclusions and
accordingly recommend that the
application
is refused and if we just asked nicola
shared to
share the presentation we'll go through
that with members
just going to the first uh
next couple uh nikki please
that's that's great thank you jared
asked question read the first slide
shows the application site it's the site
outlined
in orange and you can see the dogleg
l-shape is an existing
rough track that goes from an existing
access
to the site itself the site the building
and the
area surrounding it is in the small
lozenge to the left hand side of that
orange shape thank you nikki
this chair shows the application site
edged in red
with the other land that's owned or
controlled by the applicant
outlined in blue thanks nikki
closer up plans now chair of the site
itself the l-shaped building
is the stable building that's in situ
and you can see
the two car parking spaces identified
there that's an existing
hard surfaced apron again which we'll
see in a second
and the area chair to the left-hand side
of the building the the west
is the area that would be formed of a
garden to serve the
new welling should it gain consent the
buildings in the top right
of that slide chair were existing
buildings on the site again which we'll
see in a second so
in detail chair this is the outline
of the existing building and as we'll
see it does comprise a traditional
stable with
openings to two sides which should
formally serve the loose boxes and the
other areas associated with the keeping
of the horses
thanks nikki this
chair shows how the building would be
post conversion should consent be
granted
in general terms chair it does utilize
the existing openings which are shown
on that front then on the side elevation
with the other two elevations currently
blank
and you'll be able to see chair that the
eight roof lights
formed there they do compare with the
existing building which shows no roof
lights although in a second chair we
will see
from the photographs the um what does
look like
inside the building some light coming
through the roof so there may be some
roof lights there at the moment but i'm
unable to clarify that all i can say
chair is that the plans do show eight
new roof lights in the roof structure
thanks nikki
in terms of photographs chair this is a
photograph taken from the
site access you can see an existing
access through the hedge and to the
access gate and then the rough track
that would be used to serve
the new dwelling and the stable is the
building in the very centre of the
photograph
with the brown roof the buildings on the
right are other buildings chair
that occupied the site again we'll see
some close-ups of those
next thanks nikki
and these two photographs chair show um
a panorama sweeping across the site from
east
to west so these are the buildings that
exist on the side chair and if you can
go to the next
photo nikki we sweep round another
building on the site and then you can
just see in the the left hand side chair
the stable building and then behind that
there's the
existing tree and surrounding the garden
area which i've mentioned
and then the land in the ownership and
control of the applicant is the area to
the left chair
you may recall previously we have seen
horses and a variety of other
small-scale animals on that
that area of land that the applicant
owns and then finally
nikki just going to the next slide
please this is the
existing structure chair it is a wooden
stables as members can
see with a traditional um
tinned roof and just through the the
door on the the left-hand side you can
just see
what looks like a roof light in the rear
slope of that
roof slope although as i say chair
taken from the plans it does suggest
there aren't any current openings in the
roof
that eight new roof openings will be
formed in that area and in the
foreground here you can see the
area of hard surfacing where on the
plans it's shown that the two car
parking spaces
will be located thank you chair
are there any points of clarification at
this stage
councillor shipman
you're muted ross
can you hear me now that's it perfect
thank you
uh i'm councillor ross shipman and i
represent ward um
adrian you said in your presentation
that the building
is not considered as permanent by
officers
is that right because i in the report
itself
uh on page 21 of the agenda pack second
paragraph from the bottom
the report says that the current
proposal complies with those criteria
which one is it just in in terms of the
um outline on page 21 chair that
relates to comments made by councillor
renick
that have been reported to members in
the form they were sent to us
in terms of an office review chair
taking into account the
submit information and particularly the
comments
set out in the structural report that
accompanies the application officers are
of the view
the works that we really that would be
required to convert the building
exceed that which would normally
appropriate for a conversion
and an officer opinion it isn't of a
permanent and
substantial and permanent construction
am i am i not right in thinking though
that it's
considered permanent if it exceeds 28
days
use in a calendar year it is a building
in those terms
chair yes but in terms of how um
officers are interpreting the uh
the policy set out
to the ppf officers take the view that
the level of work proposed go beyond
those that would normally be associated
with the conversion of a building to
facilitate
appropriate human occupation in terms of
what is proposed there's
a damper of course required this works
to the floor the strengthening of the
roof
requirement to put insulation into the
building to bring it up to appropriate
standards
it's in that element chair that officers
take the view that it doesn't comply
with the
requirements to be um appropriate and in
line now for conversion without
significant works
it is a decision chair ultimately when
members of her doll that said to them
and
read the report etc you will need to
take a view on as a committee chair
whether you agree with that or not
that's the office of you right okay
thank you any more any more points of
clarification
counselor parts
mo you're on mute
sorry can you hear me now yes okay um
can you tell us are there any utilities
um
to the site as it stands at the moment
excuse me chair i mean i i i don't want
to interfere too much in the process but
this would this be the type of thing
that you'd actually talk about in terms
of the
officer questions after you've listened
to the uh speakers
and if you'd like to answer counsellor
pots the others it should just be for
clarification
sure i'm not aware that there is a
problem in terms of
laying on um utilities to the site
there are buildings there of course but
um
maybe an issue that um
the applicant or her agent are able to
advise members on in terms of the
application
form share that his proposal for the
foul sewage to be
dealt with by septic tank um and
there are other arrangements for waste
collection and etc that
are contained within that so i don't
think there's a technical reason why
the um the building couldn't be used for
human um
occupation bearing in mind the other
buildings that are already on the site
thank you there's no other points of
clarification we'll move on to the first
speaker
i'm going to invite the speakers in
order as the clerk explained
they will each have three minutes to get
over their points
they will be informed when 30 seconds
remain
as members you can ask them to clarify
any matters that have been
raised but remember your question should
only relate to the points
which they have already made if the
technology fails us
we will ask them to send us in advance a
written statement of their comments
these have been included in the late
comments report pack
i would now like to ask our first
speaker they'll be taken in order
and that is the ward member councillor
renick
we have no objectors
thank you madam chair for alarms
callisto having now had an opportunity
to visit this site to believe that a new
revised scheme
does not constitute an inappropriate
development in the green belt
my understanding the application was
initially refusing the grounds of not
being substantial construction
the change of use therefore being
inappropriate development in greenbelt
at the time the committee concerned also
expressed the extension in the
alteration of building that was proposed
however i do believe the scheme has now
been significantly amended that no
extension is proposed and the amount of
alteration
substantial use addition the structural
report has been submitted
to support its proposal which i've gone
through in detail with the agent
and think actually it does stand my
understanding is planning policy and
government guidance does allow the
conversion of buildings and green belts
to the uses subject to a number of
criteria
including that the building concerns
should be of a permanent substantial
construction
and capable conversion without
significant alteration
and extension and again i believe this
proposal complies with those criteria
the building is genuinely redundant it
was built to accommodate mrs roper's
horses
but after a serious accident she no
longer rides and now only keeps two
ponies and a herd
of rare sheep that do not need the
stabling so i'm satisfied this is not a
case perspective to the building
a stable blockman seeking a conversion
as a way of making money from this site
um but is rather a way of using a
redundant building and providing mrs
roker with a more suitable home for
which she continued
to look after her sheep and ponies but
in determining an application the
decision must be made based on the
details of the case against kind of
claiming positive background when
looking at this case in relation to
other
similar proposals it must be noted that
at least two previous applications
the conversion of the stable building of
the same form
of construction to this application one
approximately just 700
meters to the northwest of this site
were approved in 2015 and 2018.
and the considerations in these cases
were the same as a current proposal yet
they were considered
to be acceptable so i personally have
been at a loss to explain to the
applicant
how her neighbours have been able to
have permission granted for
same schemes when she has not so in
conclusion
the view this is a genuine and
acceptable conversion
that does not contain planning
regulations and does not in my opinion
in any way
contribute to urban sprawl to the
contrary i think this building would
benefit from a sympathetic
conversion and is in keeping with the
surrounding character and indeed will
enhance the royal setting
so i hope members of this planning
committee with the opportunity to review
and reconsider this proposal
and raise any additional questions to
the agent or the architect
who are also here regarding the uh
actual
uh that is reports they've now delivered
and also taking into consideration my
views as ward counts seconds remaining
and the anonymous agreements of the
atkinson parish council which also
um supported this this structural
punification
but more importantly in the interests of
consistency
and fairness i hope you consider
recommending granting the approval of
this scheme
thank you thank you councillor
are there any points of clarification
from councillor roenick
no thank you councillor thank you
i can move on to the next speaker which
is the applicant
k roper
hello mrs roper you have three minutes
reminded at 30 seconds
thank you thank you good afternoon
thank you for agreeing to listen to the
following points when considering our
planning application
we were rather disappointed with the
aspiring report
as they don't seem to have taken into
account the changes that we made to our
plans
all of which were suggested when our
last application was refused
in our planning statement we referred to
three similar conversions in the near
vicinity
one of which woodlands is exactly the
same construction as our own property
this seems to have been totally
dismissed by asparage
with the comment that it was block built
so we can only assume
they were mistaken in their research or
just used an example that suited their
narrative
they also seemed to dismiss the local
parish council's response
which is in favor of our application
saying it was a late
submission and so putting it into a
negative
life we have taken on board all the
concerns raised with our previous
application
and amended the plans and also obtained
a further structural engineers report
to mitigate all issues raised the report
mentions the lack of natural light
it's shown on the plans that each door
will become a glazed window
together with an adjacent window and
skylights
we purposefully didn't put windows on
other elevations
as we didn't want to alter the existing
building
to comply with previous recommendations
it's therefore our view that there will
be
sufficient lighting it was always our
intention that this would be
a sustainable building with wooden
construction
extensive insulation air source heat
pumps
solar power and grey water collection
as there's only the two of us a small
dwelling
more than would be more than adequate
and would release
a family-sized property so just to recap
the application has been amended to
accommodate all the concerns previously
raised there's a structural survey
to support the building's substantial
nature
and suitability for conversion to a
dwelling
and there are numerous windows on two
elevations together with roof lights to
ensure plentiful
natural light it will be constructed
following the communities and local
government's guidelines for sustainable
homes
similar applications
have recently been approved in the local
vicinity
uh both parish and district councils
support the application
um i hope that you'll consider all the
points which i've raised and look upon
our application
favorably thank you for your time and
your consideration
thank you are there any points of
clarification for mrs roper
councillor else then cather armitage
thank you thank you hi mrs rowe hi
hello just to clarify um
will you be living in this property
full time yes okay thank you yes yeah
we have a lot a home not far away
uh that's a big family home and we need
something smaller and on one level
okay thank you thank you councillor
armitage uh
thank you chair uh it's been
uh asked previously about uh are there
any mains
services already in place on the
property okay so we have solar power
uh and we have water at the moment
right so there's no there's nothing
oh sorry go on is there any mains
electricity there yet
electricity but it is on the road right
okay thank you thank you
any further questions for mrs roper
thank you mrs robler thank you
the next speaker i believe is the agent
linda trollope
yeah the site is located in the
greenbelt and the moss valley
conservation area
but planning policy in both the adopted
and new local plans
and in national policy guidance allow
for the conversion of existing buildings
to other uses
where the building is of permanent and
substantial construction
there is no absolute definition in
planning policy as to what may be
considered as permanent and a
substantial construction
in the case of a building adjacent to
the woodlands approximately 700 meters
from this site
which is not the building referred to in
the offices report
permission was granted for the
conversion of a very similar building to
a dwelling
the structural report for that
application described the building as
consisting of
20 millimeter ship black boards
externally
onto 75 millimeter deep vertical timbers
with a single brick course at floor
level
and door and window openings on the
front elevation only
the floor was a concrete slab and the
roof of timber battens supported by
trusses
and covered in metal sheeting the floor
required leveling with insulated
flooring above
insulation to the walls and the roof
trusses and buttons strengthened by
additional members
as with the current case the building
had a foundation in the form of a
concrete raft
to act as a floor and foundation which
is normal practice
to support a timber-framed building
our structural engineers report came to
the same conclusion with the current
building
which is of exactly the same
construction
that it is of substantial construction
and suitable for conversion to a
dwelling
our proposal is identical to the
previously consented scheme
the recommendation for refusal in this
case is inconsistent with that decision
the officer's report indicates that it
is not shown
or clear if glazing is to be provided
behind the stable doors
the plans clearly show that glazing is
to be installed behind the stable doors
in all habitable rooms with the external
doors to those rooms acting as shutters
for the windows
rather than as being functional doors
the roof lights already exist within the
current roof structure
the retention of the doors as shutters
is intended to retain the rural
appearance of the building
the conversion would provide adequate
light and ventilation
to comply with the current building
regulations 30 seconds remain
and would use sustainable methods of
heating and energy to provide a good
standard of living for future occupiers
in view of the above the reasons for
refusal are not justified
thank you are there any points of
clarification
councillor mo potts then councillor
foster
um can i just clarify um
if the tin roof is will remain uh and
if not what will it be replaced um
by thank you it would be another
lightweight covering
which the timber roof would be suitable
to
the timber buttons in the roof would be
suitable to support
councillor foster uh thank you chair
council foster uh board member for
coal aston um as this seems to
it looks like it seems to hinge on
whether this is um
meets the definition of being a
permanent essential construction so
for clarification could you tell me a
little bit more
um at miss trollope about the structural
engineers report and how it
um how that describes it meeting the
definition of being a permanent
substantial construction so if you if
you could give me a little bit more
information on that please
right i have the um structural report
um which says that there's no structural
defects in the building
um either external or
internal no visible cracks or defects
were noted in the floor slab
um it
accepts that a number of internal works
would require to be undertaken
but as i have stated those are exactly
the same
as were proposed and accepted by the
council
in relation to another building in the
vicinity of the site
thank you for that
any further questions thank you mrs
trollope
okay we move on to the next part
we now have an opportunity to put any
questions to the planning manager
and other officers about the application
again i'd like to keep this part of the
proceedings focused on getting clarity
about any points that you are not sure
of
once we have done this we can then have
our discussion about the application
based on all we have heard and read
sorry
nikki could clarify uh i believe the
architect was also wanting to um speak
on this
i've just got not in brackets for
questions
um i think that might have been firmed
up as the architect here then nikki tony
jenkins i believe yes he should be on
the line
because i can't see him he's at the
bottom of the screen
oh is that what i've got live i haven't
got a name tony jenkins yes
can you hear mr jenkins no
it's quiet for me
mr jenkins
hi i can see you now hello
are there any questions for mr jenkins
or would you like to speak first
well i just got some brief points to
make and um
really clarify and emphasize which uh
the agent
and the applicants of you're quite faint
mr jenkins
uh the agent and applicant have uh
mentioned these points but we just wish
to clarify and emphasize these from the
committee before
the structural survey is obviously been
questioned but it's clear from the
engineers report that the building is
capable of conversion
to a uh the foundation
is substantial and the timber frame is
identical
as mentioned to the construction
approved in the conversion of the
application
at the nearby property known as the
woodlands
um we're utilizing the
um lightweight sheeting roofing
materials
in order to minimize the roof load on
on the existing trusses and minimize any
work
required in the roof on the
issue of window openings the report as
you know
states that it's not clear that these
are shown
the stable doors have been retained for
aesthetic reasons only
with glazed um full eye openings behind
it's clear from the submitted plans that
shutters are shown on plan by a dotted
line with the window indicated in the
usual manner
we seem to have frozen yeah i think he's
frozen that chair
i'll just pause the timer for one moment
together thank you
[Music]
get back on
hello i'm sorry about that we had a bit
of a blip
on the internet am i on you are
you so it was just uh to finalize say
that
the the openings obviously have to
comply with building regulations for
both
ventilation and natural light
and they do comply the committee should
therefore with respect disregard the
concerns uh
with regards to the window openings as
it's been demonstrated that the building
would provide good living standards if
converted to a dwelling
that's all thank you chairman thank you
are there any questions at this stage
counselor armitage thank you chair
uh it's really about the construction of
the building
now you're talking about using uh
lightweight uh uh roof cladding
uh do i take it that this is something
like uh
plastic coated steel uh
which is used uh fairly largely
in and around other buildings
uh would i be writing this and uh
have taken into consideration will it be
up to spec
to uh with regard to snow loading
and things like that yeah the
the roof material is as you as you state
that it will be a plastisol which is a
ribbed metal profile
coated in plastic um that will
that will take a a snow load a
reasonable snow load um the
i think the other issue is it's
obviously
the building's got to comply with uh
building regulations so the introduction
of
insulation etc is is mandatory so
i think to question that being worked
over and above
conversion is he's not correct you know
that would be necessary in any building
conversion
that does not meet the building
regulation standards
and i take it it's uh the present
building
uh is fastened to the concrete
uh base so making it permanent
that's right there's a sole plate at the
foot of the timber frame
which is bolted to a substantial
concrete slab
right thank you very much
any further questions counselor foster
yeah thank you chair um i suppose it's a
it's a similar question that uh
that i asked earlier uh from the agent
uh i'm not so concerned about uh
that it's timber framed and no
foundations because i think uh from my
understanding you can still meet the
definition of permanent
substantial construction so it's a
it's around that engineers report on
that structural survey
uh because the recommendations from
officers seem to revolve around
uh this definition can you convince me
that
uh mr jenkins that this does meet those
uh
the definition of being a permanent a
substantial construction
that definition that it does meet the
definition
thank you well the uh the engineers
report
as uh as trump pointed out um
is quite clear there's been no evidence
and any movement
any cracking uh the building has been
uh on the site for a considerable number
of years now
so uh in terms of it remaining
stable and of a permanent nature um i
think that
explains it that uh if proven by age uh
there is no
uh no noticeable um structural
failing of the building um so
the engineers report reports what is
there you know which is a building which
is
in no state of disrepair
and uh given the fact that this is not
something which was
erected a few months or a few couple of
years ago you know this is this has been
up for
around 10 years i believe maybe a little
bit more so i think that in itself is
um is the evidence you require
thank you for that
any further questions
no thank you mr jenkins thank you thank
you
we now move on to the opportunity to put
questions to the planning manager
and the other officers about the
application
again i would like to keep this part of
our proceedings focused on getting
clarity about any points that you are
not sure of
once we have done this we can then have
our discussion about the application
based on all we have heard and read
for that reason members i would continue
to be grateful
if you could not move any motions at
this stage until we have
all had a chance to make our assessment
thank you
are there any questions for
adrian i could see councillor armitage
is waving his hand
then councillor barry
councillor potts as well thank you
william we'll start with you thank you
chair
uh perhaps uh adrian can clarify
something
uh as to what's classed as
on what isn't
and are there any standards which you
have to go by
which you can refer to
yeah there is no definition in the mppf
of what constitutes substantial but the
normal dictory definition would suggest
it's something that it
is of considerable um impact um
and as uh set out in the office of
report
the view is that the building in this
form
with the requirements needed to convert
it to
a habitable use doesn't meet that term
of being
considerable and and substantial but
there is no definition chair and it
remains a matter of judgment for the
decision maker either planning committee
in this instance
whether in the opinion of from the
information that you have the structural
report the officer report
what you've heard whether you agree with
officers or not and just reiterate share
offices take the view that
because of the construction of the
building and the works required
but in office review it doesn't meet
that definition but that is ultimately
chair
i think as council foster mentioned
that's ultimately the first
issue that members need to assess in
terms of whether
the building is not inappropriate
developed in the green belt and to meet
that test
it should be the reuse of buildings is
permanent and substantial
substantially constructed and doesn't
otherwise
uh adversely impact on the openness of
the green belt and the greenbelt
purposes j
thank you well could i come back to you
on that
so it's really it's uh as there's no
definition uh you can't really
uh use the word substantial
uh in this thing it's only officers
well it's what they think rather than
what
other people think and when you consider
that the number of
uh when we look at uh there are timber
frame buildings
uh in the area i know there's one uh not
very far from
me and there is a company
called a german company called huff
and they make these huff houses which
come together
flat packed and they just bolt them
together and your house is up within
about
10 days so i don't think you can use the
uh
term substantial because there's no
definition
on it in planning terms
yeah just uh just on that point um the
the term substantial is not an officer
term it's the one set out in the mppf
chair and the dictionary definition as
i've just discussed with cancer armitage
normally means significant in size or
value or importance or something of that
nature it suggests
a substantial construction and members
will need to take a view on whether this
is um of that ilk and just in terms of
huff houses chair
cancer armitage may um be better
first with the huff houses than i am but
my understanding of them shares exactly
as councilor
armitage has mentioned that they are
timber framed
and by their very nature they are
significant and substantially in in my
opinion
and this is currently um a traditional
staple of single
skin wooden boarding chair i don't think
the comparison with the huff house is
appropriate in those terms in this
instance but ultimately
it remains a matter for the judgment of
the decision maker
by the planning committee this this
instance to come to a conclusion on that
on that matter bearing your mind all
that is read that you've read and heard
thank you but you did if i could just
come back to you you did say
about substantial uh substantial in size
now there was no mention of size earlier
just reiterating share the uh what i
understand is the dictatory definition
members will have their own view of what
constitutes substantial i'm sure
it's just an officer view that that is
normally something of significance
thank you we'll move on from that uh
counselor barry
thank you chair adrian can you just
clarify for me that this
area is not part of our local plan
um it it doesn't appear in our local
plan as
an area for development okay
it's um within the green belt and the
countryside for
um planning purposes as asset out in
your development plan but
um just to remind members chair that uh
the mppf and your own policies don't
necessarily preclude
greenbelt development it should just be
appropriate development
if it is emitted in the green belt and
overridingly you protect the openness of
the greenbelt from
unnecessary and inappropriate in
incursion
so can i ask if if this was to go ahead
this building and there was extra
traffic to and from the building albeit
there's only two residents going to be
there but they could be family members
friends blah blah blah
would that not cost as part of the
impact on the green belt
um members will need to assess chair
whether the change of use
does have that impact of incursion into
the green belt
resulting in unacceptable development
officers on that
issued chair of taking the view that in
terms of that
impact on openness this development
wouldn't have a
an adverse impact it would be neutral
based on the fact that there is
currently
stables there that may attract in itself
comings and goings there are other
buildings on the site
sharing and perhaps um more
significantly in this case the curtains
that would
be supporting the dwelling would be
enclosed by the trees on the photographs
that we saw
earlier so an office of conclusion in
terms of that some
narrow issue of openness chair would be
that the impact of this development
would be neutral
but again chair members will need to
take a they take a view on that because
what that's one of the elements
of the um mppf and your own policies
that needs to be
assessed and developed to be not in the
it should overall preserve openness
thank you thank you councillor parts
thank you councillor barry's actually
picked up one of the points that i
wanted to make and that was about uh
traffic movements to and from the site
um if it became a dwelling because there
obviously
there aren't any people living there at
the moment and so i think that has been
covered
um the only other point i want to make
and it's just clarification really much
has been made in the presentation
about comparing this building to one
that had
permission um a while ago but is it not
correct that we are not allowed to
look at previous decisions and each
application must be
take therefore taken on its own merit
thank you um yes yeah that's certainly
correct
and other instances are often quoted at
us but
yes members need to take this decision
on the merits of the application before
you and again as i've mentioned all that
you've read and heard and to
be away from that just because something
else may have been
approved or refused would not be
appropriate you need to consider this on
its own merits yes indeed chair because
the circumstances around other
um other buildings other applications
could be different and
issues taken into account by the
decision maker in those instances may
also differ
any further questions
no thank you for that adrian and this
leads us to the final part of the
process
our discussions about what we've heard
and what we think and where we want to
decide
but before going any further i would
like the clerk to remind us about
motions right thank you chair
uh please bear in mind members that a
motion must be moved and seconded
before a vote is taken if an amendment
to a motion is moved and seconded
then the amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendation
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a move if a motion to reject officer
recommendation
fails or in other words it is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion
in favor of the recommendations or
another course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
thank you chair thank you
having heard and read everything today
and the officers recommendations before
us what is the view of the committee on
the application
i am now opening the floor for a motion
councillor barry councillor foster
chair i'd like to move that we go with
officers recommendations
counselor foster i was going to propose
a different promotion and that would
give planning permission
for reasons i can outline okay
in fact uh would you like me to outline
those reasons now let's
speak now because somebody may have
wished a second
yep uh it seems to revolve around uh two
issues here
one in that the building meets the
definition of permanent and substantial
construction
uh i'm already satisfied uh that it does
uh from uh from the engineers report and
from what i heard i've heard today
um i know that timber and timber framed
and
uh buildings with no foundations still
meet that
permanent and substantial construction
it's been there 10 years
so i'm happy with that on that part i've
heard enough to say
that it is permanent substantial
construction so that's uh the first
thing the second one
uh when it says in the second part of uh
the recommendations from officers
uh about uh lack of openings to
facilitate natural light on that part
we've heard that it
will follow building regs so i think it
i think it covers that covers that part
uh it's the same footprint it's not
affecting neighbours
and we already know it's not going to
affect the
the openness to the green belt so i'm
happy with that
uh we've heard that the eckington parish
council
and the ward member are both in favor of
this
uh planning permission being being given
so for me uh all that's enough and i'm
happy
to propose that we give planning
permission
um for this i second it
chair thank you councillor shipman i saw
you had your hand up
you're muted you mute ross
hello and that's it all right um i i
also agree with
council of foster and councillor
armitage um
i think the fact it is under everything
i can look at when i've been doing some
research
it is it meets the definition of a
permanent structure
under the town and country planning
general permit development order in 1995
it defines that a permanent use is a
property which exceeds 28 days in any
calendar year of being erected
therefore i mean this has been up what
ten years did the um
the presenter earlier therefore
to me it meets that um definition
um which to me means that should have
the opportunity to convert it obviously
if they meet then
the um other conditions i say this every
meeting but we do need to be consistent
in the applications
uh that we're deciding on if one of
these i know
like uh planning officers say that we
must discount the planning applications
that come in
but the reality is if one's been
converted from the exact same structure
and actually
our policies that we've adopted
subsequently have only gone on to
support
that sort of development of course we
have to look at it and make a consistent
decision
in favor of approving this uh
development i don't know about anybody
else but i actually love this
development development
it's it sounds to me like the most
sustainable development that we've had
in front of this planning committee
since i've been on here um and i think
that the fact that it's not connected to
the mains is a great thing in the use of
solar power you can have ground source
heat buttons
it's got everything going for it that
means we should be approving this and
shine from the rooftops like we need
more of this in northeast option not let
us
i'm absolutely in favor of this and i
fully support council fosters
and armitage's motion thank you thank
you
counselor barry i saw your hand was up
uh
yes it was um also um councillor rita's
hand was up before mine actually
um i want to come back a bit because you
you sort of jumped in with what you want
to say before we'd have a chance to even
second the motion that
i put forward so i i sort of
contradict what you're saying because i
don't believe that the structural
engineers report
gives us what we need to say that it's a
permanent structure
i'm not happy with what they've read out
on what i'm afraid to say
um as far as you know
new developments i don't mind new
developments and especially ones that
are going to be green
but not in the green belt we've been
fighting hard to keep our green belt as
green belts
and this is sits outside of the uh the
local area
um it's in our green belt it's not part
of our local plan
and therefore it should not be taken
into consideration and as it said before
it's each case on its merit we don't
i can't remember what the rules and
regulations were around the others that
have gone through
but as far as i'm concerned we're taking
this i put a motion forward
um i presume that council reader was
second in that motion
um but i'll leave it over to you now
chair
council arena i'm sorry i can't see you
very well it's very dark in there
but if you'd like to speak now please do
yeah i did have my hand up before com
will the moment interrupted me
and seconded council foster so i was
going to second councillor barry
and i was sort of drawn to 8.3 in the
report
regarding it not really being a suitable
building for residential conversion and
much to what
councilor barry has already said so i'm
a bit disappointed chair that i didn't
get to put my
my second in at the right moment
um but you're running the meeting so
we'll just see what happens
okay i'm going councillor foster and
then i'm going to speak to the clerk
uh yeah thank you chair uh the first
thing uh
i i couldn't understand there is some
confusion when people put their hands up
and it's difficult uh to see who wishes
to speak
uh as chair you did ask both myself and
counselor barry to speak at the same
time
uh so i accept that and i did speak just
after counselor barry
um there is a motion uh
i put forward it has been seconded i'd
like to go to the vote on that
uh but uh just secondly with regards to
what councilor barry
uh mentioned there about the green belt
the green belt there isn't the issue um
we've already been told by officers that
it wouldn't be harmful to the openness
of the green belt so it's that it's not
that way actually
it's a good point that we want to
protect the green belt but that's not
the case here
uh that's not been argued that it would
affect the openness
it's uh it's the other two points that
uh that were mentioned in
recommendations
and those are the two points i've
addressed in
uh in the motion so uh i don't believe
it will affect the greenbelt
greenbelt at all that's not a question
so i'd like to move to the vote
and then we give planning permission for
this this development
thank you i'm going to uh go to our
clerk element
just first the clarification on the
order i should be taking this
in well essentially chair um you've got
two motions
but they are diametrically opposed so i
don't think you could actually say that
one would be an amendment to the other
the first motion
which was seconded was that um the
committee
um go against officer recommendations
and accept the application i'm sorry and
accept the application out
i'd suggest before you actually move to
the vote on that um
you'd need to probably clarify as to
what exactly the reasons were
and for the purposes of um sort of the
you know the decision
so anything that you'd need to say on
that adrian
just on that chair i do think that uh
councillor foster has identified the
reasons why
he believes that the um
[Music]
that permission should be granted in
this case i'm i'm happy that uh
sufficient reason has been set out why
that would be the cater so i don't think
in this instance if members are
minded to grant consent that any further
justification is needed but
what i would say uh share is if you do
take the vote on that and permission is
granted that
um ideally uh that permission is granted
subject
to any necessary conditions chair being
delegated to myself in consultation with
yourself and the vice chair
thank you yes so we've got a motion
and it's been put to after you've gone
to the vote so council of foster
would you like to put your motion again
to the committee
does it need any further clarification i
can go through it again if you like
let's give plenty permission for those
reasons i mentioned okay is everybody
happy with the clarification
with the final conditions being uh
determined in consultation with yourself
and the planning manager chair
i'm happy with that yeah so we've had a
seconder by councillor armitage also
followed up by rob shipman can i please
now have a show of hands
no chair we're going to do this sorry to
apologize
i do
thank you chair so if members could
clearly indicate
for against or abstain after armitage
fall castle barry against
counter cooper abstain
that's elliot
you're a mute peter
against thank you mr foster
four how's the huckabee
you're on mute carol
four counterparts
against casa powell
for councillor reader
against cancer ridgeway
against castle rouse
against council ruff
paul castle shipman
you're on mute mark ross
sorry i was just making sure that that
was coming back before i gave the result
we have four
uh six votes four six against with one
abstention which means the vote is tied
and that could go to your chair's
casting vote
four on that basis then uh the motion
would be carried
thank you
thank you everyone we can move to the
next item
it's at like application 4b
which is ned forward slash 20
forward slash 00570 forward slash fl
over to you adrian
apologies shows uh myself um
i do a brief introduction share before i
ask nick if she'll share the
presentation with yourself and members
and in this case chair the applicant is
seeking consent to construct a lob
log cabin to be used as a holiday
let the cabin chair would be
2.5 meters high can be constructed
with a slate roof access to the cabin
would be via a footpath through woodland
from a parking area that would be
created close to the road chair and in
this instance
elements of sustainable energy would be
attached to the building chair the site
in this case chair is located within a
special landscape area
where new development is permittable
providing it does not detract from the
surrounding landscape but in keeping
with the countryside
and not in a prominent position and
therefore creating a prominent intrusion
the policy chairs set out in the
national party policy framework are
generally supportive
have suitably scaled and designed new
tourist development
and reflect the council's emerging local
plant policies although as members will
have note
noted from the officer report the extant
development plan policies are somewhat
um
behind that and don't conform in officer
opinion to the mppf policies and
therefore
should be attributed to limited or very
little weight
and the neighborhood plan share also
seeks to protect the countryside from
inappropriate development but again
does not preclude development if it is
appropriately designed and located
officers have concluded share that the
chalet associated development
is suitably designed and located such
the integrity of the local area
would not be harmed issues of highway
safety and ecology chair are considered
adequately addressed
now such officers conclude that
development is acceptable
and have accordingly recommended the
permission is granted i'm just ask nikki
chair to
share the share the presentation
there we are that's that's okay this is
the uh the slightly exaggerated but
that's where access from the road would
be formed
the parking area there and then the
narrow strip would be the
um foot access to the site itself which
is
an area of meadow set within
thank you nikki
this chair again has customary sets out
the the application
site you can see the proposed log cabin
chair
the other buildings that surround the
site comprise
the um
say with with respect to the hamlet of
brockhurst it's a limited collection of
buildings chair
forming together but the site is is
located in proximity to those and
particularly to the
former mill which is where the the
applicants
reside and you can see the other land
owned by the applicant
chair set out in blue on that slide
thanks nikki
just in some detail then chair the um
dog leg to the left-hand side of the
slide is the highway that's mill lane
and then members will be able to see
access from that
there's currently a gate there but it
would be an area of parking that would
be located
close to the road and then a foot way
that would
be formed through and over an area of
trees
to the chalet which you can see which is
the red square the center of the
the drawing is set within a field
that is then surrounded by other trees
as you can see their chair and you can
see the applicant's property brockhurst
mill
just to the southeast of the application
site
just within the the other land etched in
blue
thanks nikki this is the uh
building itself chair it's a
limited building in terms of size with a
with a room with two
and a living room with two bedrooms off
and a bathroom you can see it's a
cruciform formula as you can see there
the the reference to the
panels in the roof that's one of the
features that i've just mentioned in
terms of sustainability so there would
be solar panels on the on the roof chair
thanks nikki i think we've now chaired
to some photographs this is the
existing access off the the highway
chairs an existing gate there
this is the area where the parking area
would be formed
then you can just see off to the center
of the photograph there's the woods
there but the the footwear would go
towards the right hand side
of that photograph you just make out a
wall going from the roadside wall in a
direction straight forward from the
photograph so the footwear will be
formed through those trees
and it's up and over a mound and that is
forms part of the opposite conclusion
that generally speaking
the the cabin itself would be well
screened from
any public viewpoints and there is a
public footpath that runs
across the other side of the stream that
we'll see in a second that would only
provide
limited views of the cabin from
from there through a tree screen chair
thanks nikki
it's a couple of photographs of this
location chair that's now looking in the
other direction the gate that we've just
seen on the left hand side you can see
the wall that i've mentioned
there on the left hand side and against
that would be the footpath that would
go from there through the trees thanks
nikki
again chair that's just looking in the
other direction again you can see the
walls in the foreground on the right
hand side
just in the very near foreground is the
stream
that would run then back through the the
woodland round the mound that i've
mentioned and borders the site
thanks nikki
this is looking back from where the
footwear would go chair back towards
the road you can see the gate and just
in the wall there and that's where
the parking area would be formed and
there is a
assessed pit proposed chair and that
would be located just beyond the trees
on the right hand side
just in and adjacent to the um the
footway
thanks nikki
and this is the mound that i've
mentioned here the the footpath would go
from the middle left of the photograph
behind those trees
and over the mound that you can just see
in the middle right of that photograph
towards the application
site thanks nikki
this is the site itself chair the the
cabin will be formed
on the left-hand side of this paddock on
the right you can just make out
a stream that's referred to in the
officer report chair and this is the
tree screen that i've talked about that
would surround the site
meaning that um the building located
here would be
difficult to see from any direction
although the footpath that i've
mentioned
is to the right hand side of this
photograph beyond the trees that you can
see there
and it runs roughly from there along the
top of those
those trees through the field you can
make out in the distance of the
photograph
thanks nikki
then here chair the the site is to the
left as the the meadow the paddock that
i've talked about this is a stream on
the right hand side
and members will uh will note from the
report that the the site itself is
within the flood zone one
and not an area that you normally
associate with
with flooding on a normal basis
thanks nikki
again share now looking back across the
site this is
from within and adjacent to those trees
i've mentioned the stream you can just
make out in the
foreground of this this photograph so
the application
site is the paddock that's there and the
building itself would just be on the far
side of there just underneath the bank
on the far side
thanks nikki
thank you chair thank you
this is just a quick one is there any
qualifications regarding this
slides that you've just seen before we
go on to the speaker
no thank you i believe we've only got
one speaker
for this application and it's the
applicant harry caldecott
hello hello mr caldecott you'll be given
three minutes
and then you'll be reminded at 30
seconds when your time's
so nearly you'd like to introduce
yourself and off you go
i am it's harry caldecott the occupier
with my family of brockhurst mill
and first and foremost thank you all for
allowing myself to speak at today's
committee
where i simply wish to offer a better
background to ourselves as a family and
our intention in terms of this
application
having been brought up in the asheville
parish my wife and i are very
attached to the area and instantly fell
in love with brock ismail when we
stumbled across the property quite
unexpectedly
since becoming owners we have worked
tirelessly on the mill and surrounding
area paying particular care
and attention to its heritage and
character at all times
we've planned to make broca's mill a
home for life where we believe the work
we've done to date is testament to our
core values
respecting all those that have gone
before us whilst enhancing the property
an area for future generations
more specifically and in terms of our
planned proposal
from the very outset we have gone to
every length to ensure we have put
forward a suitable and sustainable
proposal
that meets a wide range of criteria
having spent a great deal of time
considering all forms of building
structure we have settled on something
we believe to be truly unique and
and importantly an asset to the local
area thereafter
we began an even more challenging task
of ensuring we could not only build the
cabin itself
but also access and use the facility
year-round
without compromising the natural
landscape and habitat which remains
central to our overall proposal having
engaged with the derbyshire wildlife
trust armstrong ecology
and various members of the local parish
and walking clubs we are pleased to have
come up with a solution that appears to
tick all the boxes
whilst also enhancing
and the bio diversity of our site
we appreciate and have embraced all
feedback and suggestions put forward to
date
in terms of the cabin guests will park
within our site just off mill lane where
they will then embark upon a mirandewing
path
specif specifically designed to not only
protect but enhance
enhance the natural flora and fauna this
symbiotic relationship with nature will
remain central to our guest experience
during their stay
and we hope encourage them to visit
again guests will be encouraged to stay
local and make most
make the most of everything our truly
unique area has to offer
where we hope our one-of-a-kind offering
will encourage people that may have
never visited the area before
on arriving at our proposed kabul cabin
guests will be
will be completely secluded immersed in
nature and away from all neighbouring
properties
guests will find the cabin to be made of
fully sustainable and recycled products
with the oak structure and stone slate
tiles ensuring it blends seamlessly with
both broncos mill itself and the natural
landscape in which it sits 30 seconds
remaining
finally and before i run out of time as
a family we remain acutely aware of the
responsibility we will undertake should
planning be granted for our woodland
cabin
by this we're not only talking about the
natural and built environment of
broadcast mill but also the wider
community and hence further reason for
us to ensure our cabin is designed
constructed and maintained to the very
highest standards should anyone have any
further questions i'd be very
happy to answer thank you
do we have any questions
um councillor ridgeway you were up first
then
councillor armitage yes thank you for
that
um my my only concern is i've been
looking at the pictures
is um i think it's a beautiful sight but
how are you going to construct this
without knocking trees down to get
are you using diggers to dig the area um
i just wondered how you actually going
to construct it without damaging the um
the area that you're going to build in
yes um it's a very good question and
that was uh we
we we undertook a an ecological report
and
engaged with derbyshire wildlife trust
to make sure that we could access the
site
with a small digger which would be
required and without removing any trees
at all now there are actually two ways
into the
site where the digger would be required
both of which can be achieved without
removing any trees
and thereafter once we've completed the
work we actually hope to plant more
native species and enhance it further so
i'm
extremely confident we can do that at
the right time of the year as well so it
won't be
done during the winter for example uh
where we'd rip everything
up or you know it will but there is a
strategy in place
and i you know i'm probably not
explaining it overly well but i would be
happy to better demonstrate that but um
yes that that was a great concern of
ours as well truth be known
councillor armitage uh thank you chair
well uh i must admit you've done a good
job
at the mill and you to be congratulated
on that uh
there's one thing that concerns me and
that's the
septic tank and its location
now as far as i'm concerned septic tanks
need to be emptied from time to time and
uh there's no road access
to get a tanker or anything and to empty
it so
you will have to make a road i'm quite
sure was
is that correct and the other thing is
uh
you mentioned that it's for all year
round
uh occupation this uh building
would i be correct in that
hello um hello william yes and
the um second with the second question
yes it would be for all year round
accommodation that's the intention
that's what we would
hope to achieve i know it might be a bit
wild and rustic in the winter but
um guests that come here we would uh you
know
we'll be made fully aware of what to
expect so if they
if they if they want a red carpet
rolling out they're going to the wrong
place you know they want to go to the
ritz or somewhere this is a different
experience but
in terms of the cesspit where we've had
it located
um you would be able to access it from
the road and
they can pump the suspect just like our
if you in fact
the same method of emptying the cesspit
for our current property would be used
for
emptying the um cesspit for the proposed
cabin with the
i think it can go up to 40 meters in
terms of the piping to
train that but admittedly the vehicle
would be parked
on the road during that period of
emptying the suspect tank
potentially and it might be possible for
them to come onto the parking area which
we plan to construct if necessary but
it's never been an issue in terms of the
mill itself today
are there any other questions
thank you mr hank hardcort are there any
questions for adrian
oh very blank okay
so now i open the floor for a new
discussion
counselor barry
yes chair um basically i don't think
there's an awful lot to say about this
application i think it's been well
thought out so i'd like to go with
officers recommendations
thank you is there a seconder
and our second nature council well i've
got lots of hands going
but councillor ridgeway was up first
okay is everyone happy to move that to
motion if we go for a roll call then
nicki
minaj if members could clearly indicate
for against or abstain
cancer armitage abstain
counselor barry four
cousins four
house elliot four
house
i'm just asking you to meet your
microphone four
how's the pause
for how's the power
that's a reader
or that's a ridgeway
four that's a rouse four
master rough four and council shipment
four okay
i make that
eleven votes for with two abstentions
the votes carried thank you thank you
very much everybody
so just to clarify officer
recommendations have been approved
thank you we'll move on to the final
application
which is ned forward slash 20 forward
slash
zero zero double four six forward slash
f1
one over to overton lodge jetting street
mill town ashoka
over to you adrian yes thank you chair
first of all if i
may refer members to the late report of
yesterday
chair referencing in particular
paragraph 8.4 of the officer report
chair in this case chair the applicant
is seeking consent to create
two additional off-highway parking
spaces
the area of land currently comprises an
area of planting and vegetation across
jetting street from the applicant's
own dwelling getting street check rides
the right of way
and the site again lies in the open
countryside in a special landscape area
the parking chair would be constructed
of a permeable surface with a wall and
planting area behind and we'll see that
on the drawings in a second
policies of the plan chair seek to
protect countryside areas from
an acceptable development in this case
chair officers conclude that the eastern
side of jetting street retains a rural
character
as part of a wider countryside area
sitting between jetting street
and the river amber that the
formalization of the parking
facility would erode that character and
that's led to the
primary element of our um recommendation
chair
members will note in the report that a
heritage statement has now been
submitted
and interim comments have just been
received from the county council
archaeologists
who and based on the submitted
information still retains an objection
to the proposal on that basis
um he does however chair and advise that
there may be
ways forward of addressing that or
mitigating it so chair
view of the the late receipt of those
comments it's my
um suggestion to members that if members
are minded to accept the officer
recommendation on the substantive point
an additional reason for refusal um in
terms of the
the county council archaeologists is it
is added
and that may either be addressed through
any resubmission
or um addressed by um the secretary of
state on appeal
if members chair reminded to approve the
application contrary to officer
recommendation i.e
and must take the view that the parking
area will not have an adverse impact
overriding impact on the special
landscape area i would suggest chair
that decision is taken subject
to an appropriate resolution of the
matter between the applicants
and the council with the help of the
county county architect county council
archaeologist and that's in consultation
with yourself and the vice chair
chair or if resolution can't be found a
chair that the matter is then brought
back to the committee for
final determination if you
can just go to the presentation now
mickey please
i just have to scroll through a few uh
nikki please
okay chair in in this instance as i say
the the application site comprises part
of
the applicant's existing uh ownership
and you can just see in the center of
the slide here chair and jetting street
which is the road i've referred to and
the applicant's existing dwelling will
see that on some photographs in a second
is the area to the west side of jetting
street
the area to the right side is the other
area of land owned or controlled by the
applicant and the parking area proposed
is to the right-hand side of jetting
street members may recall
chair that um certainly some members
will recall that
commission has been granted further
along jetting street on the
west and the southern side for three
additional dwellings to be constructed
there and we'll see
part of how that is coming forward on
the ground in a second in one of the
photographs
thanks nikki as
say chair the the application site is to
the right hand side of jetting street
you can just make out
an element of what's proposed there the
the applicant
is owning the area that's outlined over
to lodge there
the area to the right hand side also
part of the application sites yeah the
area
outlined in blue is a site that has been
granted consent for
dwelling house and relatively recently
some members
may recall that and again as i say chair
we'll just see how that's beginning to
take place
on the ground in a second on one of the
photographs but you'll see jetting
street
coming from the the south and the
primary highway network
up between the two elements of ownership
and then
towards the the north west and on the
right-hand side
is the river valley the amber valley
it's just
alongside where you can see path
in brackets that's where the the valley
of the
river amber is thanks nikki
so this is the the existing situation
the
um large block in the the center of the
slide is the existing
dwelling house the area the the
rectangular
shape to the north of there is an area
that falls within the
application site that has consent to be
used for a dwelling house again we'll
see that in a second
on the right hand side of jetting street
you can just make out this there's a
variety of
um elements there but there is a
planting area
and a small wall that we'll we'll see in
a second that's the existing situation
if nikki can just flick over to the next
slide we'll see what's proposed and
that's
the area now that would be formalized as
a as a parking area
so there would be a wall and a planting
area
to the east and northeast side of what
would constitute two
more formal parking spaces
thanks nikki
i think move on to the photographs now
chair
the the um applicant's
house is the building you can see in the
middle of the slide there and presumably
his vehicle to the right hand side of
there
if members can just note that because
it's exactly opposite there where the
two parking spaces are
proposed and you'll be able to see on
the right hand side the area that
officers
take the view retains a aurora character
and a feel
and into which would be the parking
spaces
the heritage issue that's been raised is
that the embankment on the right hand
side of jetting street
is the embankment that used to carry the
railway that used to
access the the quarry further long
jetting street and it's that element
that the
county county archaeologist is still
seeking some
some solace on that the merits of that
line would be retained should consent be
granted
if you go into the next slide mickey
please it's just a close-up
shot of that area you can see now just
beyond
where the fence is in the middle of this
photograph and just
opposite jetting street from where the
cars parked that would be where
the parking area would be formed into
that vegetated area on the right hand
side
you can go to the next slide to nikki i
think that's even closer
shot that's looking in the in the
direction
looking from the application site chair
back down jetting street
again we put that in to try and um
example
what the officer view is in terms of how
the one side of jetty street
chains aurora character as opposed to
the other area which is
which is more and domesticized in terms
of feel and appearance
thanks nikki
this chair is the area opposite where
the vehicle is this is where
the parking area would be
added so the the parking area the
dimensions set out in the report chair
would be into that area of vegetation
that you can see there which members
will will see and as noted by the
the county county archaeologist in his
uh his uh constituted reply to us the
significance of the the embankment has
been
marginalized in this era already and
it's not as marked
and i think that's what's made his
comments
um to the effect that there may be some
mitigation or some way of addressing
any loss of non-heritage asset
information in that area but again chair
and i've set out what i propose
members do should they believe that is
an important element
thanks nikki
looking in the opposite direction chair
the you can see the building in the
center of the
the slide the single story element of
that like that bit
closest to the photographer would be
removed and that would then
form part of the site on the right hand
side which consent has been granted for
the construction of a dwelling house and
the
the blue vehicle there is part of the
works that have
recently started to form the level pack
platform
for that uh dwelling house to be and
placed within that site and i so that's
one of
three units that consent's been granted
by the council of the dwelling house
which is on that side of jetting street
the application side chair is further on
and it's opposite the two-story element
of the building and that's at both ends
as bookend by the chimney
so the application site where the excuse
me the parking area would be formed
is opposite that area of the building
you can just see the low
um wall which is on the other side of
jetting street opposite that dwelling
house and that's where the parking areas
would be located and again chair we've
put the photograph in to
seek to example why officers contend
that that side of jetting street still
retains that
feel of rural character as opposed to
the more now
domesticized feel of the western side of
jetting street
i think maybe one more nicky
not for the first time no i'm incorrect
thanks
thanks chair thank you are there any
clarifications regarding the slides
before we move on to the speaker
no thank you we've got
two objectives i believe and so we'll
start with those
so mr david thomas i've got in brackets
mike
what would you like to be known as mike
please
thank you okay um mr thomas you've got
three minutes and you'll be reminded
when 30 seconds
are remaining you can start anytime
you're ready
thank you chair i've submitted a written
objection to this application
but such is my concern about the
creeping urbanization of the area
and the threat to its exceptional
qualities as a landscape
i wanted to take the opportunity to
address the committee
in looking at the applicant's latest
submission it's clear that their
architects have been a little economic
in replaying the reasons
why the first application and that's
double0125 was rejected
and contrary to their claims the revised
proposals do not address the reasons
given
for refusal of planning permission last
time indeed the recently received
heritage impact assessment
clearly demonstrates that the scheme
would have a direct impact in terms of
stripping out vegetation and soil
erection of fencing and removal of stone
walling
potential damage and destruction to be
low ground features or deposits of
cultural heritage value
so the applicant's archides proposals do
not mitigate this impact
in recent years the applicant carried
out unauthorized excavation
of this embankment and was required to
carry out reinstatement
if this proposal were to be accepted
then it would set a precedent for the
removal of more of the embankment in
other places
this part of jetting street leading onto
the bridleway
is a very popular walking route used by
both locals and visitors from the wider
region
and part of a popular very popular in
fact circular walk from the village to
mill town
it's the beauty of this landscape which
of course led to designation as a
special landscape
area and attracts visitors it's
something to be cherished and protected
the applicant has no satisfactory answer
to ashover's neighborhood plan policies
ap one limits of development
and mp13 landscape character
the reasons for rejecting the
application this time are as sound as
they were the first time around
and i asked the community please to
reaffirm your refusal
thank you thank you are there any
questions
no thank you mr thomas and the next
speaker is roger waterhouse
mr walter house are you there yes yes i
am can
are you receiving me yes i can hear you
you have three minutes
uh when you're ready and you're reminded
when there's 30 seconds remaining
thank you um
i really have three or three reasons for
objecting
uh which are very similar to those
already said spoken by mike
the first is to do with heritage milton
actually is not bashover it's the hamlet
which is down the valley from
from ashoka it's always been a working
hamlet of miners and quarry men the
local pub
is the minus the area is littered
with mine shafts from lead mining and
what its particular development came
after extraction of lime
during the 19th century
and then in the 19th century into the
20th century
quarry works the quarries brought
prosperity the actual jetting street was
actually the hinge around which
the um the industry moved
the ash of light railway kate started
his build there
and went in to play across bringing
flospar in there
that heritage finished when
the the quarry is finished the milton
quarry which is the one that the track
that this
the railway track led to mentioned
closed 75 years ago
the the adjacent quality quarry
closed only recently that means there's
a lot of brown land
and that means it's right for
development and it is being developed
as you've already reported but the
development is changing the character
completely
as industry moves out nature moves in
and that is why we have such an
attractive part
of what used to be an industrial
wasteland
and as mike has already said it is
heavily used
by local people and by people who come
looking for the heritage
the heritage bit has been eroded and
eroded and eroded
and this last bit which is now being
applied for
will be one of the last bits to be
eroded so
i objected on grounds of heritage i
object on grounds of
despoiling the landscape but the third
thing is that underneath the bank
which is being proposed for removal is
the main water supply
for several dwellings my only included
and there is no that's not referred to
at all in terms of the planning
application
thank you very much thank you are there
any questions
counselor armitage
thank you chair hi uh
yes you mentioned the water main uh i
remember it
uh quite well because lower down from
there
uh there was uh
a lay by built and your water supply was
cut through
if i remember uh and i put that in my
my written my written objection yes
and yes i can see your point
on that uh the
am i right that the uh ash over light
railway
uh that there there are plans
to uh get it going again
would i be right in that
[Laughter]
there is a dream but
most of the actual light railway was
drowned when augustine read
was flooded right
okay that was just just my point about
it
thank you any further questions
no thank you we'll move on to the next
speaker
which is the agent malcolm cook
mr cook are you there
hello hello right you have three minutes
mr cook
and you'll be reminded when there's 30
seconds remaining
good afternoon thank you for giving me
the opportunity to speak in support of
the application
we wish to confirm that the proposals
are actually for these the residents of
numbers one and two
overtook lodge who have no other such
facility
um we know the objectives comments we
would add that the
um the resolutions allowed further
design work to address the comments in
terms of levels
appearance and heritage of the
development
the proposal seeks to secure an
appropriate level of parking without
disturbing traffic flow and jetting
streets
proposals are agreed by the planning
officer as being acceptable for a
privacy and immunity point of view with
no adverse impacts upon nearby
neighbours and properties
the proposals are confirmed has been
acceptable from a highways point of view
but we would like to stress the positive
impact of the development
the objectives note that this part of
jetting street in bridal way which
passes
through it is heavily used both by
locals and visitors from the wider
region
it is part of a very popular circular
walk from the middle east to middletown
and back
by providing the party checking street
is no longer narrowed by parked vehicles
allowing the free flow of traffic
preventing conflict with pedestrians and
horses and so improving the immunity for
all
this was demonstrated by the photographs
presented by the applying officer
we note that the heritage impact
statement which is being provided
uh it doesn't look that the previous
removal of the original embankment
which was agreed with the planning
authority some time back
and the effect of the trees and scrub
reduces the research potential of the
embankment here
that report suggests a moderate impact
upon the significance of any surviving
remains of the quarry line embankment
this will be mitigated by a scheme of
archaeological monitoring
to identify and record any below ground
remains that may survive
the opportunity to discover and record
such remains before their further
deterioration
is a further positive impact of the
development
the impact from the landscape has been
addressed by the design
the scientific adjacent the roadway and
the layer by design
with parking parallels to the road is a
common feature in the open countryside
the proposals will not be incongruous
and the development includes a
construction of
the 0.4 to 0.6 metre high
burn faced with reclaimed stone and
planted
was forming an attractive feature
respecting the environment
and being a significant improvement on
the existing arrangements which is no
more than a line of stones along the
back edge of the highway
the seconds remaining further
consideration is the sustainability of
existing dwellings
acknowledge the location sustainable and
the residents do not need to rely on the
motorcar
parking for a vehicle is one of the
requirements of one day living
the provision of parking for the
dwellings ensures their long-term
sustainability
in addition we know that in 2007 the
embankment opposite brookside cottage
and similarly remove that objection to
create two poppy spaces and remains as
such
in summary the development is similar to
existing arrangement opposite brookside
cottage it will ensure time chair
sustainability of the existing drawings
at overton lodge
the lay by design and plantar walls are
appropriate to the location and of high
design quality
and in addition there will be
improvements to highway safety
benefiting the users of the public
rights
cook your time is finished i'll ask now
if there are any
uh questions from the committee
councillor foster councillor armitage
uh thank you chair uh just some clarity
on you you mentioned that it's for
parking
for number one and number two
um and in highway safety considerations
uh 7.22 on page 54 of our papers
at the bottom it says to provide parking
for two vehicles to be used by occupiers
of number one
so just some clarity on that point first
whether it's for one and two or just for
number one
and then secondly uh some clarity
on whether um will there be any other
parking for
uh occupiers of number one and number
two
uh if uh this is not granted
thank you yeah numbers one and number
two uh both in the same ownership
and neither property currently has
parking endlessly the vehicle is carved
on the road
and obviously the photographs the road
is very narrow
thank you for that councillor armitage
then councillor barry
uh thank you chap uh it's just the fact
that
you're asking for two parking places
well over the last uh
two uh years they've there's been about
three
cars parked there and as
the ownership uh of the
uh land adjacent where the old stables
are
uh i mean couldn't that have been used
for parking uh such as
a suggestion then you don't have to buy
uh taking
month and would i be right in saying
that that embankment was taken down by
the
current owner and he was told to put it
back
to its uh correct height and
this hasn't been done
i understand that the the works to the
bank would agree with the planners at
the time
right what about the fact that you're
asking for two
uh uh
spaces when there in fact there's been
three cars
parked there for a constant time i
couldn't comment on the cars at the
point but it seems reasonable to
request in terms of you know
sustainability of the drones at
one parking space for each
right thank you
killster barry
thank you thank you chair um i think
mine's on a similar vein to what
um council armitage has just been saying
um can you clarify that the land behind
that's now being developed
um belongs to the person that's asking
for these two car parking spaces
it is so can i ask why
it was not thought of when you put those
applications in
that he should retain some of that site
in order to park his cars
there isn't sufficient space on that
side
to build the size of houses that he's
wanting is that what it is so therefore
it has a knock on effect to the parking
uh the site is actually quite it looks a
large site but it's actually quite steep
and the house is built into the banks in
fact it's there's not such an awful lot
of development
a developable land on that side so
sorry again for clarification the two
small stone buildings that you see that
are only single story
am i right in saying they're coming down
that's correct yes
thank you
are there any further questions
thank you mr cook
are there any questions for the planning
officer
counselor barry
it's not so much a question i think it's
more about moving officers
recommendations
have i got a seconder for that if
they've counsellor ridgeway
councillor potts council pots did you
want to speak or were you just seconding
seconding right everyone's secondly
counselor armitage
william we can't hear you uh
i i do quite a few things about this
application
uh and that that road
uh uh it feeds
uh quite large uh error
[Music]
grassland and from time to time
well two or three times a year it's moan
and it has to come out
via that road and then it's mucked now
the problem is these cars are parked
there
as it is and nothing can well it's very
difficult
to get large tractors and trailers
through
and some uh some provision has to be
made because when these houses
were originally built uh going back in
time they were the
workers of the quarry workers and uh
there were there were no cars as such
now
as time's gone on the uh
the road has been substantially narrowed
by the fact that the cottages have put a
little
sort of flower bed in front and they've
narrowed it by about two feet
now you can't get a
large tractor and trailer through there
when there are cars parked
[Music]
you keep breaking up liam
and i'll load that
sorry it might be worthwhile actually um
putting your um your camera off it might
actually be easier that way
i'll try that right
i've gone into nothing
but i'm still here uh yeah everybody
else has traveled away at it as you
could see
by because that that embankment went all
the way
down uh well miles down the road and it
eventually came out in clay cross
and everybody's traveled the way without
planning permission may i add
and the latest one was just lower down
and that was when mr waterhouse's water
main was
chopped through uh and i did report it
uh
as to what being uh illegal uh what had
gone on
and i was told that it was perfectly
legal to have done it
now this guy has gone about it the right
way
he's asked for planning permission and
it's being refused
uh and well the officer's recommendation
is to refuse it now
people have to be able to park the cars
and
people be at house to be able to get
back past these well
well these park cars as it
is there's problems with delivery vans
because everybody orders online uh they
can't get through
the farmer has great difficulty getting
through
past these so there has to be a
provision of parking
i don't know what the answer is so i'm
leaving it to you
there has to be a provision for parking
because it's a narrow pinch point where
it is
and you must take this into
consideration before you start to turn
this down
out of hand thank you william uh
going to speak to uh councillor foster
then ross shipman
and councillor barry then we must come
to you and move this motion forward
counselor gloucester uh thank you chair
i didn't realize we'd already opened uh
the floor for uh motions uh
that's that's that's the first thing i
didn't realize we'd already done that
um perhaps i wasn't paying attention
there uh
what i'd like to just make the case for
is uh the highway safety considerations
um i get the points that people have
made and they get the objections
and i also understand the
recommendations and how it fits in with
policy
i understand all of that but i think we
ought to all of us consider here
uh the highway safety considerations is
a concern of mine
um and you know i think perhaps we ought
to put greater weight on that when we
come to deciding whether this wants
to be given permission or not i can
understand uh
people feeling well when you when you
build these houses you should take into
account
uh these things why should you have such
a big house and then afterwards look for
uh parking elsewhere i understand those
points
uh but from where we are now those
houses are there
i'd i i can only feel that
you know it would benefit the safety of
the road and the highway
for horses for walkers and for other
cars
um so i'm inclined to
think that it would be a good idea
against officers recommendations
uh whether i feel strong enough to put a
motion i'm not sure but uh
do you know i think we should i think
i'd like to hear from other people what
they think on the highway safety
uh i don't think we've discussed that
enough before we move to a vote
on any motion thank you thank you
councillor shipman
thank you chair i'm i find myself
agreeing with councillor foster and
armitage again here i think
if we're if we're all truly being honest
i don't and that application for the
houses next door had come before us at
the same time as this i think we
probably would have rejected that
um but we are where we are now these
houses
um are there potentially more being
built
uh if you look at the photo where the um
the vehicle is
um seen from the presentation it's
it's it's you know it's not it's
it's stopping fire engines ambulances
you name it getting up that road
so we as a planner for us need to take
that into consideration
i'm not over the moon that i'm
potentially being
you know i suppose convinced to approve
it
against my you know my own heart if you
like but
at the end of the day if you were the
other end of that road and you wanted
some emergency services coming through
you'd expect us to take that into a
consideration when we're coming to put
on
to approving an application and i i
think
reluctantly i'm probably gonna support
a motion to reject officers
recommendations and actually approve
this
so i think it will improve that road um
you know and i think i i i'm
i'm going to put a motion forward in
that in that vein
thank you counselor barry before you
come in um
adrian would like to say a few words is
that okay
yeah i didn't necessarily want to um
interrupt the debate but just a couple
of points i just wanted to
mention to to members as the debates
going a long chair first of all
that as we've discussed a couple of
times during the meeting already this
application needs to be considered on
its merits
and in that respect chair members will
need to first welcome to a conclusion as
to whether the development is in
accordance with the policies of the
development plan or not
and if it isn't according to the
development plan then um i.e there isn't
any adverse
impact on the the character of the area
then you should be granting permission
for it unless there are other matters
that
outweigh that and conversely chair in
terms of the development plan if you
consider
that it is adversely impacting the
character of the area then you need to
consider all the matters whether they
outweigh that so in terms of
the issues that council foster has said
it talked about
highway safety etc and other matters
they are material matters and members
can
put them into the planning balance but
you need to come to a decision first of
all on whether it's in accordance with
your development plan policies are
either proposed in accordance with your
development plan policies
and then when other material matters um
take into consideration whether they
affect that first conclusion so that's
the the process that you need to
to follow chair just in terms of the
issue of the other development i know
what members are saying about that
but in those other cases i recall that
in those cases
the parking to serve those dwelling
houses
is catered for on site so that wouldn't
be
an issue that would lead to additional
car parking or shouldn't lead to an
additional car parking
in those circumstances and just finally
chair just before
you were you take any emotions put
forward i would just welcome a chance to
come in just
remind members in respect of the the
archaeology matters and
just to get clarity on how members may
wish to deal with that
i'll help again chair if members would
like any further advice
thank you councillor barry then
councillor shipman
yes thank you chair um as far as
this case goes and we're taking you know
like we keep saying one by one
everyone's different and to be treated
in its own merits
i'm sorry to say william yes i
understand the farmer might have a
problem but that's not part of this
issue
and shouldn't be taken into
consideration um
i think it's not in accordance with our
development plan and i don't think it
should be
um i don't think emotions should be put
forward to go against officers
recommendations
i think if those people that live in
that property
have built a walled garden outside the
front
on the on the public highway as it would
have been
then those walls need to be removed um
so that will widen that
uh roadway again um
i think it it
it just strikes me as being a bit odd
the fact that this person
knows they need parking but then goes
ahead and does developments
on another part where he could have
actually utilized some of that parking
and i think if we start to let them
encroach onto our historic grounds
and because the archaeological people
don't agree with it then i think we're
going to step too far
so i'm you know i'm sticking with my
original thing to stay with officers
recommendations
thank you councillor shipman thank you
chair it's worth pointing out actually
the the over the um over ashover parish
there's many many many passing places
which you would almost
which will this will look like just in
any other passing place as far as i can
tell because
the roads down there are very thin they
aren't meant for
double traffic um and you know
yes we need to take this application on
its merit but that doesn't mean we can't
take it outside factors that will affect
this application um and i think we do
seriously need to look at actually
proving this to improve the area in my
opinion uh because
you know cars are gonna be parked along
the sides of those uh
properties anyway so therefore you're
still getting a row of cars there
it's just we're talking about a matter
of here between you know are they right
up and
against the building or are they five
meters away and i think that
if this can improve the road layout as
well as offering these residents some
parking to get
so we can allow emergency services to
pass and i think we really need to
consider that
councillor armitage
yeah if i could just come back on that
it's not just a farmer
we're talking about we're talking about
people higher up the valley
uh and we're also talking about dustbin
lorries
now there's a dustbin lorry that goes
there it's a special small one
and it has to back down to one of uh to
mr waterhouse's
property to being able to get in uh
and that's a sort of thing that they
have to uh
come by and you know
there's got to be some uh
some sort of uh lay-by or something
constructed where these cars get off the
road because one day
someone's gonna have a heart attack
they're gonna have to get an ambulance
down there pretty quickly
thank you any other questions councillor
foster
thank you chair uh i'd like to support
council shipment and his comments
uh and to say he was a little bit ahead
of me there and i should have been on
the ball when it came to emergency
services but uh a very good point that
uh you're not going to fit a fire engine
down there um
with those vehicles parked there i can
understand people's frustration about
this should have put car parking spaces
there
they should take a wall down that's not
within our power
it is within our power now to put to
give permission for two parking spaces
to make it easier for all residents uh
so that these ambulances can get down
bin lorries can get down and uh and fire
engines too so all of those things
uh and for myself um
i don't know how we'd work it into a uh
emotion but i'd happily support
counsellor
shipman and second emotion if he was uh
so inclined to
put one together thank you chair
thank you councillor shipman yes yeah
i'll put a motion forward to go against
officers decisions on the basis that
um i i don't think it's a an issue
i think it is i think it does fit
the development plan in the fact that
we're actually
um providing um
we're providing space and to park away
from the road and therefore making it
a lot easier for emergency service to
travel down there for ramblers to use
that
area um without the being unnecessary
danger to those that are actually using
that road
uh we can you know we can talk all day
about you know shoulda coulda woulda
the fact is a previous decision has been
taken and we are now at a stage where we
need to
take a positive decision on actually
what we're doing with it and we can like
counsel the fosters we can actually uh
introduce this parking space and make it
a lot easier for the residents
and surrounding areas
thank you counselor ridgeway
yeah i just want some clarification if i
can
um so if we agree to
give them the two parking spaces and
then people park
people are going to have two more spaces
to park alongside that road
so to me it's not going to make any
difference because people are still
going to be parking
to park their cars to go rambling um
am i right or am i wrong
[Music]
if it's something different that we've
already heard
yeah you're wrong i walk that road uh
twice a day with my dog and
on many occasions it's quite uh it's a
tight fit yeah i'm a big glad
i know but you know when you see people
trying to get
through and delivery vans trying to get
through because the sat now
uh says it's okay to uh
then you know i have to uh combat that
together with the
off-roaders at the weekends uh quad
bikers
and all the rest of it and with those uh
cars parked there it's a hazard and and
that's all there is to it
uh i can't see it's gonna make much
difference
uh to the environment or anything like
that because it's
all the way down people have made their
own and that
embankment's been got rid of all the way
down
and this isn't going to one extra one
isn't going to have a great impact
and after all those cottages didn't the
question of somebody having the cottage
uh building something there with no
provision
those cottages have been there since the
1800s
when there were no cars but now there
are cars
and we have to pay provision for them
thank you and
right i understand that adrian wants to
come in here
adrian we can't find it yes just very
briefly uh if you're moving to the vote
on on the motion put forward by your
counselor
shipment chair and i think just for the
record we would we just need to be
clear that um members um in
taking their their decision either do or
don't consider there's an adverse impact
on the the character of the area because
if
if they don't then it's in accordance
with the drug plan as i think as council
shipment alluded to
and therefore you don't need to have
significant matters to outweigh
that conclusion as if um the conclusion
was that there was an adverse impact
then you would need to
state that and the other factors
outweigh that harm
and just finely chair and just before
you do move to
to the vote on council shipment motion
which i believe is the next
next step and just how we deal with the
archaeology
archaeology issues and the option for
members would be to include a condition
as set out in the submitted
archaeology statement that there's a
record taken of any
archaeological features that are found
and the other alternative chair as i
explained at the start would be to
see if a resolution could be found to
that matter that does of course
um leave open uh issues that council
shipment council foster haven't
discussed ie
potential of coming back on that issue
alone and i again i'm not
sure from the debate that that's the
intention of counsellorship and council
the foster
my understanding is that you would be
happy just having a condition on to
ensure that there is appropriate record
taking of any archaeological factors
that have found chair
thank you councillor shipman thank you
chair yeah i i
i don't think there's an adverse effect
i think that you know
like i said there's there's labels all
throughout the parish of oshover
on these tarots just because there has
to be um
in terms of the archaeology thing um
supposedly we can delegate that to
yourself to be satisfied that the
necessary
surveys or reports of submitted to the
district council
and if a planning manager and yourself
chair
are satisfied and they can proceed with
laying the tarmac and whatever else the
next step is after that
thank you i'm just going to confer with
alan
um alan because counselor barry has put
a motion forward and it was seconded
should that be heard first
well i think we're in a similar position
to the previous application chair we've
now got
two applications the first of sorry two
motions the first motion
was to approve officer recommendations
and that was seconded
and then we have the second motion which
is basically to reject officer
recommendations and accept the
application
so again i think they're diametrically
opposed so from that point of view
um i would have thought that sort of you
would have to take the first motion
first and then depending on what happens
on that motion uh move to the second
thank you councillor barry would you
like to put your motion forward again
please
yes chair i'd like to move that we stay
with officers recommendations
um that are detailed in the report
councillor ridgeway are you still happy
to second this motion
thank you nikki can we have a roll call
please
yes of course uh members if you could
clearly indicate for against or obscene
uh the vote for would be to refuse the
application
against council barry
or councillor cooper or
council elliot against
household foster against
counselor huckabee
that's happy i'm just giving you a
prompt to a mute uh
and against
has your pots
for how's the power
against cancer reader
or cancer bridgeway
core castle mouse
or
how's the shipment against
okay chad that is seven votes four with
six against and zero absention which
means officer recommendation to refuse
has been carried
thank you
thank you all very much we can move to
item
five planning appeals and determined
everybody happy with that yes thank you
and item six is a matter of matters of
urgency
now although there's no uh matters of
urgency
i would ask that if at all possible
members stay on
for some clarity to discuss the paper
that was sent
out to you and there's one other item
that's come on board as well
um if everyone's happy with that
okay chip are you now formally ending
the meeting thank you
okay thank you chair so if we could stop
the live broadcast
you